you were dancer you're very successful
dancer in your country I mean in my
County I was in the top 15 as a child
from ages 8 to 12 I'd like to shoot that
dance to plot a very traditional very /
very and very hot heart what is a say it
again to me it's schuhplattler
schuhplattler or perfect you super supe
rattler oh shoot I also feel like you
got to make a face - and you do some of
these German with shoot rattler
Oh a little shoe table oh it's like your
face is a semicolon
[Applause]
and then you're doing it to a really
goofy
goki so so that what kind of dancing was
Bavaria that's in the south is that the
South time it's like the Louisiana of
Germany yeah yeah
what is that Karen so you're from the
deep south of German Oh deep deep south
okay so and they have traditional
dancing there yeah the soup lat la it is
very nice dance with lots of leg slappy
and foot heads okay do you want to show
us Road yeah show us a little foot
slappy hit hit yeah yeah okay
maybe
[Applause]
oh I didn't think you were dancing look
like you were swarmed with invisible I
know you really did look like you needed
to just yeah you were infested with some
kind of insect this was developed during
the bubonic plague chief has that done
to my music form bah bah bah boom da
boom da boom that's yes the first one
right well that was that was fantastic
now there's so much Conan last time you
were here I enjoyed you on the show so
much last time I enjoyed you on your
show so much last time you as well Andy
Andy thank you
these are unnecessary sentences but last
time you were on the show I enjoyed you
so much and you were very kind you said
at the end that you would you were very
nice you said Conan come to Berlin come
see Berlin with me and I'll show you
around
yes please I would show you all the
messy sassy times well we decided
because we do travel our show
occasionally that yes indeed we're going
to take our show to Berlin we're going
to go there and shoot
[Applause]
we're really looking forward to that yes
I cannot wait to go Wow Wow
will you take me in holy bulent rimoni
yes no I leave you and we're gonna leave
on a plane tomorrow
what yes on a plaintiff oh yeah let's
cancel all the residence we looked into
it you had nothing going on so we're
gonna go together and we're going to go
so people of Berlin we're coming you're
gonna see us there over the next week
and say hi what do people say they know
how low baguettes Conan okay all right
just wave to us we'll find you
yeah see you in Berlin everybody in the
next couple days buddy moon is available
on demand and iTunes Flula Borg you're
always a Georgia
[Applause]
you